what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and i
know it's late on sunday night and i
normally don't even post on sundays but
it is a special occasion because we do
have an official confirmation of when
the real actual release date for the
hawkeye trailer is and this is coming
from jeremy renner hawkeye himself he
posted to his instagram story not even
an hour ago telling us that the hawkeye
trailer is coming tomorrow that's right
we're getting the hawkeye trailer
tomorrow now when can we expect to get
it tomorrow it looks like it's going to
be in the morning so jeremy renner
originally posted to his instagram story
simply stating that the trailer is
coming tomorrow but then in another post
he said tomorrow morning also not to
mention marvel studios has had a habit
recently of dropping their trailers
pretty early in the morning so they're
pretty much staying consistent with this
i'm assuming so if we go based off of
what the releases have been for previous
trailers in the past we could probably
say that the hawkeye trailer is going to
drop at maybe 8am or 9am eastern time in
the united states and if you're
wondering what timezone that is for you
you can just type it into google now as
far as what to expect well we can expect
to see kate bishop played by haley
steinfeld and we may also get a glimpse
of to what hawkeye is up to after the
snap and what he was doing kind of
between those five years from the first
snap to the hulk snap and bringing
everybody back and although this is the
first trailer it may not so much be a
teaser since it's for a disney plus show
so we probably will actually get a lot
of plot details and learn what the story
is really about what is the hawkeye
series going to be about why is hawkeye
training kate bishop what is he training
her to do why is he specifically
training her what did she do in her life
and who are the bad guys all of this
hopefully will get a little glimpse into
tomorrow morning so again keep your eyes
open around 8am or 9am eastern time
because that is probably when the
hawkeye trailer is going to drop so be
on the lookout for the trailer and then
be on the lookout for my breakdown i
also post about these things on twitter
and instagram usually before i do videos
so if you want to stay up to date even
quicker be sure to follow me on twitter
and instagram don't forget to like this
video and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof